the Joe Rogan experience but the guy
behind this tattooing him he's got does
he got some that's making Mickey work oh
that's that movie Harley Davidson and
the Marlboro Man what movie is this from
movie oh there's another movie could be
Expendables scene or something
Mickey Rourke is an acceptor he's the
kind of guy that would come over your
house with like a full Indian jacket on
with like the tassels my favorite actor
skin and like he would have buckskin
pants on and like legit cowboy boots and
you couldn't say nothing nothing a big
turquoise belt buckle and no shirt yeah
no shirt when he was younger my favorite
actor of all time one of those ties
calls this is just a string yeah the
western time yeah you know I'm talking
about what is that [ __ ] thing yeah
that's a fake tie that's what that is
that's whatever he wants and it's not a
time and carry around two small dogs in
his hands oh yeah yeah and maybe a gun
maybe a gun maybe a bow around his neck
whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah yeah
maybe walks through your house with a
knife and his teeth yeah look what's
going on with Mickey just make a even
it's just they gave him alone just as
regular Mickey yeah the world of actors
my friend they are out there he was
abused by his stepdad really well was he
yeah
you take great a great interview with
Alec Baldwin on Baldwin's podcast called
here's the thing it was very
heartbreaking very heartbreaking he was
abused by his um his his stepfather was
a cop and a brutal son of a [ __ ] and
really abused those two boys well his
brother Mickey's brother died in his
arms Oh drug addict because of his
father he blamed his father as his
stepfather
then he saw his father he'd never seen
and he's so heartbreaking till the story
he saw his father in New York father's
come out of a bar his father goes Nicky
was stand there and he was I'm your son
his father goes I thought I'd run into
you one day and then his father died a
week later of alcoholism
see if we don't pan into him as a grown
man yeah yeah you tells you everything
about someone you know your hearts
broken at a young age well almost
everyone
that's [ __ ] up in this life is [ __ ]
up because of something that someone did
to them whether it's a relative or abuse
that they suffer or you know things
throughout their life that have gone
horribly wrong especially for children
the big one I mean that's the most
formative time of your life right when
you meet people that were abused as
children you everyone like universally
feels for them you're like oh no when
you have children especially oh for sure
you realize what a catastrophe and an
impossible thing to deal with that
that's so terrible to me it's the
special evil you know it is abusing
children I mean you're ruining not just
a moment but the full potential of a
child's life they're never gonna escape
the fact that that was done to them but
someone used them this child
psychologist she wasn't stalking her and
I said give me some advice with my
children you know she said right she
goes just don't leave just me in their
life that's big and I was like that's
true right because when your dad's not
there your mom's not there if someone's
not there this is like the feeling of
like displacement everything's wrong the
worlds and then on top of that what
these kids get abused it's like oh my
god you've you've compounded horror on
top of of sadness and loneliness horror
on top yeah and it's also it this is the
really [ __ ] up things it repeats
itself like they say that people that
are molested when they're children are
much more likely to more or less
children which is like the Saints it's a
thing that happened to you the abuse
that happened to you it's almost like
you want to put it on someone else did
the fact that there's so many kids grew
up in single-parent households in this
country is the problem that's the
problem that's a job you can talk about
racism you try everyone else you grew up
without a father you grew up in a
single-parent household that's that is
that's abuse
that is meds men who have children men
who have children and walk out on those
kids that those the people I have no
time
I hate him I don't give a [ __ ] what your
excuses you have I would make it a law
like you you'd be I would make it very
uncomfortable but that's just one kind
of abuse there's also abuse by your
actual biological parents there's a
service by other biological relatives
isn't there's there's people that is
abused by stepfathers and that's your
brothers and sisters there's abuse by
neighbors there's this abuse man but
it's all boils down the same thing it's
like what happens during your
developmental period when you're a
really young person to becoming an adult
and once if someone's abusing you and
[ __ ] you over that just ruins most
people's lives
most people don't bounce back from that
you know and then you get caught up in
this spiral of this cycle of crime and
violence and prison and abuse and you're
done you're done
[Applause]